en Ecuador el año 2023 comienza con un
proselitismo político atípico es que a
partir del 3 de enero se desarrollará la
campaña electoral durante 30 días en el
que coincidirán dos eventos electorales
y un referéndum constitucional siendo
este el que concentrará la mayor
atención de los electores Ecuatorianos
ocho preguntas que estarán en la
papeleta de referéndum 2023 en el que el
gobierno impulsará modificar la
constitución en temas como la
extradición de criminales relacionados
con el crimen organizado y el
narcotráfico y en la elección de
autoridades de control como los temas
más polémicos de la consulta las otras
preguntas estarán relacionadas a la
reducción del número de asambleístas la
independencia de funciones la fiscalía
la auditoría constante de partidos
políticos y los métodos de selección de
autoridades de control entre otros
además la creación de sistemas de
producción hídrica y ambiental un
referéndum constitucional con el que el
gobierno pretende afrontar sus
principales retos del año 2023 de
seguridad violencia manejo de las
cárceles reformas laborales e inversión
social entre otros en medio de un
contexto de constantes enfrentamientos
políticos entre El Ejecutivo y el
parlamento El Ejecutivo aspira mejorar
su imagen y se jugará su capital
político muy reducido en menos de dos
años de gobierno